وفي الجوانب السلبيه هذه المره
التكنولوجيا الاتصال في حياتنا اصدر
الجراح العام الامريكي
مرتي تقريرا نبه فيه الى ان وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تشكل خطرا على صحه العقليه
للاطفال
ودعاء مرتي صانعي السياسات الى المزيد من
التنظيم في استخدام منصات الانترنت من قبل
القاصرين وسلط الضوء على الاضرار المحتمله
التي قد تلحق بالاطفال والمراهقين بما في
ذلك الحرمان من النوم ومشاكل الصحه
العقليه والتنمر والوصول الى المحتوى
العنيف والاباحي كذلك ويوضح التقرير ان
الاطفال والمراهقين معرضون بشكل خاص
لتاثير وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لانهم
يمرون بفطره حساسه للغايه من نمو الدماغ
لكن على الرغم من القلق اشار مرسي الا ان
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي قد يكون لها
فوائد محتمله للاطفال بما في ذلك تعرضهم
للاخرين للاخرين الذين يشاركونهم هواياتهم
وخبراتهم والسماح لهم بتكوين صداقات
واقامه علاقات والتفاعلات ايجابيه عبر
الانترنت